hello everyone thanks for joining us for
CNN second annual virtual symposium
advances in drug discovery and
development
I'm Lisa Jarvis senior correspondent for
CBN and I'm delighted to introduce our
next speaker Derek Lowe Derek has been
working in the pharmaceutical industry
since 1989
I'm drug discovery projects ranging from
schizophrenia Alzheimer's diabetes and
osteoporosis but you probably know him
best from his blog in the pipeline where
he provides astute commentary about the
science and business of developing drugs
rather than percent of formal talk will
run to session like a Q&A just as
Derek's blog inspires and insightful and
civil discourse about the drug industry
were hopeful that today's audience will
be equally participatory some
housekeeping if you want to submit a
question just click the green Q&A button
in the left hand corner of your screen
and if you need any technical assistance
during the presentation please click on
the support button located on the top
right of your screen and if you want to
follow along on twitter the hashtag is c
e & sy m15 please note that CNN does not
endorse any company products or services
that may be mentioned in this
presentation
this talk will be archived and available
on demand at the conference website for
three months after the live broadcasts
so until December 16th while you get all
your questions into the queue I'm gonna
kick it off with the perennial question
for the chemists in the crowd um Derek
would you tell students interested in
chemistry to go into drug discovery
today and if so is there a skill set you
suggest that they develop or a path to
take that would help them be the most
successful in today's drug discovery
industry I'll turn it over to Derek okay
that's
a perennial question alright I get that
a lot and I guess my answer is is that
the skill set that you need is to be
ready to change your skill sets because
this is where chemists for biologists
for law scientists this is a lousy time
to be an average scientist in a
high-wage country like the US or Western
Europe or Japan for that matter we get
paid a lot of money and there are a lot
of people in less expensive parts of the
world who are willing to do what we like
to do in companies of course are always
looking to save every expense they can
as long as the work gets done so you
need to be able to bring something that
is not so easy to outsource and in many
cases what that means is you need to be
able to do things that are new whatever
the latest instruments are the latest
techniques the latest ideas you need to
be keeping up with them you need to be
keeping up with the literature you need
to be keeping up with your field because
the days where you could say well you
know you should you should pay me
because I can run lots and lots of
suzuki couplings or I can I can set up
libraries a lot of people can set up
libraries a lot of people consider
suzuki couplings so that's not going to
get any more you really have to keep up
with things have an answer when someone
if someone comes to your office door and
says hey why do we pay you why are you
here why do why do we keep you around
you need to have I guess sort of an
elevator pitch answer a quick answer I
do this I do this thing and it's
important for this and you don't have
anyone else who does it or you don't
have anyone else who does as well as I
do
great um well we're gonna jump from a
really broad question to one that digs a
little more into some some hardcore
chemistry a question from the audience
what computational chemistry advances do
you think can can or will have the
greatest impact on drug design over the
next several years back over to Derrick
please okay yeah computational chemistry
I'm sure I have some colleagues or
groaning at the thought of me giving
another opinion about computational
chemistry but even though I've had my
ups and downs with it over the years
there's no doubt that you know it's
driven partly by Moore's law which is
still moving along pretty well although
you wonder about the next few years it's
straight being driven by advances in
software and advances in understanding
which come along more slowly but they're
still there so it's getting better all
the time
whereas other branches of chemistry are
including but maybe not quite at the
same rate of course computational
chemistry has a pretty high mountain to
climb too especially considering what
people are the assets do you over the
years but one of the things I'm
interested in watching is the
free-energy perturbation methods that
some companies are exploring people have
been talking about this stuff for years
but it's been computationally sort of
prohibitive to do and it's still major
burden you have to have some pretty
serious hardware to make a dent with it
but I think that area has a lot of
potential
I just don't know yet how much that
potential is going to be realized I'd
like to see some some real-world
applications the good thing is if people
can get this to work we're going to see
real-world applications because the
companies that can do it are not going
to be shy about telling everyone that
they can do this so free energy methods
I guess are the first thing that I think
of beyond that they're of course a lot
of other things under the umbrella of
computational chemistry but I think what
the first people the first thing people
think of with computational work is can
you predict which molecules I should
make
can you rank order this bunch of
possible n logs and that's what I think
the free integer stuff really has a
potential place to he's got a lot of
computational China so I think watching
right now because we're getting a lot of
questions on that topic um here's a more
general question you know about
epigenetics is viable drug targets in
your thoughts on on whether those are
going to succeed I'm guessing someone's
referring to the genetic drugs that are
in development to treat some forms of
cancer you want to weigh in on that you
feel comfortable on that one we can go
over to Derek oh it seems like we've
lost Derek for a second so we will try
to reconnect him and hopefully he'll be
back briefly because I see the questions
lining up in at you okay all right I'm
back all right epigenetics that is a
tough area because it reminds me a
little bit of the nuclear receptor area
as it was say back in the late 90s early
2000s actually the nuclear receptor area
as it arguably still is this is an area
where the biology is extremely difficult
it's very interesting it's very
complicated and it clearly is going to
control a lot of stuff but that's the
promise and that's the peril because it
controls so many things that it can be
hard to separate out the effects that
you're seeing with any given se small
molecule acting on an epigenetic target
if each one of these targets is
controlling dozens or hundreds of
downstream events genetically that's
that's a pretty big knot to untangle and
I don't
we know yet enough to say I worried that
it's going to be one of these things
that's going to take another five or ten
years to really undo all these strands
and figure out what the best way to go
is but of course people aren't waiting
five or 10 years they're charging ahead
there are a lot of companies charging
into this I wish them the wrong look I
think that some of these things are
going to work but some of them I think
it may be one of these cases where you
not only have to be good you have to be
lucky
I mean look back at the nuclear
receptors the the best nuclear receptor
drugs where the PPAR gamma compounds
that were already in development before
anyone even knew what the target was
most of the nuclear receptor work that
came after that during that for room
time in the early 2000s ended up not
leading anywhere when it got to want to
come to the clinic or even preclinical
so it's something that I don't know I
hope for the best but I'm kind of glad
that I don't have a lot of money tied up
in that myself
okay well interesting response and so
we've gotten a few questions about
compound libraries and whether you think
that the quality of the compound
libraries that are in existence either
in-house or commercial are good in US on
yields you know good leads I'm maybe let
me let me try to tie two of these
together because a related question was
our large company running out of
compounds to screen and their high
throughput discovery so maybe you can
can weigh in on where we're at with high
score put screening sure I don't think
there's any danger of running out of
compounds compound space is of course
gigantic it's ridiculously huge and
we've got new synthetic methods coming
online all the time so I don't think
we're running out of content
now as far as how good these libraries
are whether they're good enough to come
up with leads that's a tricky one
because if we had our current compound
libraries and we're running things you
know 3540 years ago these would be
spectacular the kinds of targets people
are screaming in I'm sure they really
light up things all over the place but
targets of course are not getting any
easier
occasionally we'll come up with some
pretty good-looking target through
biology and genetics efforts of course
the hope back when we sequence the
genome was that there'd be dozens and
hundreds of these out there but that
that hasn't exactly turned out like that
but a lot of targets that we're looking
at are getting trickier and the kinds of
chemical matter that are going to work
for them are probably getting trickier -
you can find all sorts of suppliers
right now who will sell you
protein-protein interaction optimized
libraries I have no idea or the library
of compounds optimized for
protein-protein interaction is going to
look like except there probably are
going to be big and ugly and of course
as you get to big molecular weights the
potential Universal compounds gets
bigger and bigger and bigger so your
chance of sampling that space gets
smaller and smaller so I think that the
compound libraries we have are probably
a lot better than they ever have been
people are paying a lot more attention
over the years to to qce to compound
diversity toward culling things that are
frequent hitters for Payne's type
compounds all sorts of false positives
we're getting better and better at
weeding that stuff out but at the same
time the targets were we're expecting
these compound libraries to deliver
against are getting trickier with more
probably more unusual chemical matter so
it's an arms race right now I think that
we are better off than we have ever been
but the question of is that good enough
is still an open one depends on what
kind of target you're screening on some
of the for instance epigenetics the last
topic that came up some epigenetics
targets if you screen against BRD for
you will probably find some chemical man
you can get a flagman ski excrete and
get perfectly good fragrance however
there are a lot of those other
epigenetic targets you can screen all
day and as far as I can see you won't
find very much at all so if the answer
varies I hate to pop out like that I
mean someone has JP Morgan one time
weren't the stock market look Dearing he
said the market will fluctuate whether
or not your compound library is given up
depends completely on what kind of
target you're screening against okay um
this is a broader question but you know
the nature of drug discovery is such
that you spend a lot of time writing
about the failures just because we see
more failures and successes but I
wondered if there's ever been an
instance where you doubted a drug
discovery approach or technology or
target and been surprised when it
actually works or I guess if there's
anything that you're seeing in the
pipeline that you're really hopeful is
going to work that is some really cool
technology oh yeah I've been surprised
definitely I guess I'm enough of a
pessimist where I figure that most
things are not going to work so when
something really does work I'm very
pleasantly surprised but I have been
I've had some things that didn't look
like they were going to work out that
really did fly right and they they feel
right at several different points some
of them the SAR opened up and suddenly
we found a whole new series of compounds
that we didn't realize was even there
sometimes we would be very worried as we
went into say two-week talks because we
are convinced that x and y and z would
probably happen and it didn't look or
sometimes something else happened but
yeah I have been surprised on the upside
but of course if you're going to talk
about drug discovery if you're going to
give a more or less honest picture of
how it really works we're going to end
up talking about failures because of
course the clinical clinical failure
rate is still pretty much 90% so there's
just a lot more
things that don't work and do for now
that's our big problem as far as
technologies and things in the front
line that I I'm really curious to see
how they're coming on I can cop out and
say the the amino oncology stuff is
spectacularly interesting the big
question is how far can it be extended
to how many different heroes of cancer
can we get away with this
what are some things about the immune
system we don't know yet that we're
going to find out as we start doing this
so the immuno oncology stuff is
extremely interesting a lot of the
biological and BIOS small molecule
hybrid stuff I find extremely
interesting as well there's of course
all the RNA stuff out there I realized
and I'm including the the anti-sense
period in the early 90s where it looked
like anti-sense was just going to come
in and wipe everything out that was
going to be in every single target you
can think of Sarabhai antisense and that
didn't work out and I don't think that
everything's just going to get wiped out
by si RNA but between si RNA between the
messenger RNA stuff that mogera and
other people are working on between the
cell based therapies like the immuno
oncology and the gene editing type
technologies those are a lot of really
interesting stuff going on
of course you notice most of these
things I'm talking about have a strong
biological component and that's what I
think medicinal chemists we have to we
have to shove ourselves into this we
have to find a role in assisting these
things biomolecules small molecule
hybrids modulating these processes or
small molecules for instance right now
people are testing the T cell America
energy stuff along with pd-1 inhibitors
we need as medicinal chemists to find
wherever we can to make a home to make
to come to an accord with all this new
biology because otherwise we risk
becoming less relevant in some of these
areas
I like that phrase coming to an accord
with new biology and you bring up amino
oncology and that ties in nicely with a
question from one of our viewers which
is you know socks on I mean you do I
think I don't think this is necessarily
what you're referencing but thoughts on
what this how small molecules can play a
role in a needle oncology you know maybe
I'll just build on my question how
significant of a role do you think they
could or my slave yeah I can't give too
many details on this because the amino
oncology is not my field per se although
I'm extremely interested outside
observer but just the combination I
mentioned before with the with the CAA
are key stuff and pd1
that is one role and I think that might
be sort of a prototype but the kinds of
interactions we can we can look for we
need to find whatever immunological
levers and checkpoints we can that might
be amenable to small molecule control
now there aren't a tremendous long list
of them but there are some and I think
that we should be pushing with maybe
some where they're out there screens to
see if there are other things that we
might not think are amenable small
molecules but might be there are huge
numbers of interactions that we really
either don't screen for or haven't had
too much success screening for in the
past and I would adduce on protein
carbohydrate interactions which of
course are important for immune response
as one of those that might be an area to
start pushing into and see this gets
back to the chemical library question it
might be that the kinds of compounds
that most people have in their chemical
libraries would give a little bit rates
for something like that fine
go outside the box a bit hey using that
phrase outside the box I should be
beating on the head
for using that what try some different
chemical matters some more unusual
looking chemical matter and see if you
can get things to happen in this area
this is another one where if you're
going to screen and some of these things
the existing libraries may not be enough
of a bit but we're going to have to find
these things otherwise I mean biology
has been making some really tremendous
strides recently and you know one one
good thing is to sit back in a plop then
which I do the bad thing would be to sit
back and grumble about well these people
are there they're pushing us in other
way we're gonna be uploaded
don't be outmoded get up and do
something better okay well we've touched
on and you know on ecology which is
obviously a really hot topic and so with
a lot of success that we've seen I want
to kind of turn the coin to Alzheimer's
or we've seen a lot of failure and a
kind of chicken or egg question and one
you know wondered what you're gonna see
first a good mechanistic understanding
of disease like Alzheimer's that then
helps us design drugs or we'll be fine
finally getting some drugs on the market
that help us then understand what's
actually happening with the disease you
need give us some of your thoughts about
where we are in treating disease like
Alzheimer's and maybe more broadly other
neurodegenerative diseases and whether
you think there's any technologies that
are emerging that could help us solve
some of these really tough questions
chicken-and-egg with with all sign
there's chicken and egg that's a tough
one because when you think about it the
Alzheimer's compounds that have gone
into the clinic the ones that are in the
clinic now and the ones that are headed
there are mechanism based they are
target based because people are looking
at amyloid processing for the most part
or they're looking at just sheer that's
going to signal in the earlier
generation or even if we're looking at
town or whatever these are mostly
target least mechanism-based things so
as those compounds are in the clinic
then we can start saying something about
whether or not these particular targets
are really relevant to Alzheimer's for
example looking began a secret ACE
inhibitor that Lily had in the clinic
and failed terribly it actually seemed
to make the Alzheimer's slightly worse
we have people arguing that this wasn't
a good enough gamma C for today's
compound this wasn't a fair test and all
that and you have to worry though
because that's a little bit like the no
true Scotsman fallacy you know a real
gamma secretase compound would have
worked I don't know I don't know that
may have been a real gambit see for
today's compound I mean now I have beta
secret ace compounds we have the the
antibodies that really are trying
desperately get work that Genentech
neither subscribe amyloid hypothesis is
not yielding as readily to this stuff as
you might hope and with again as with
the gamma sequences you could say well
that's because the amyloid hypothesis is
right but we just haven't hit it with
the right agents or hit it hard enough
with these agents or you could say that
the only one hypothesis is maybe not all
there is to it I'm not don't know which
way I come down on that I'm going to
stay agnostic on I used to work in
Alzheimer's a long time ago and if he
told me that it was 2015 and we'd still
be arguing about whether or not amyloid
is the proximate cause of the disease I
don't know what I've done you know
banged my head on the window and tried
to jump out or something I can't tell
you it's black the progress has been
very very hard on people so we're going
to get some answers with the things that
are in the clinic now but if you want to
find a compound that we're just going
and help people with Alzheimer's I guess
you would need a phenotypic screen and I
don't see how to do a phenotypic
Alzheimer's screen because there's not a
good model for Alzheimer's on any level
out on the cell level not on the animal
that well I mean they're better than
there used to be but is there anything
that people are confident enough to say
yes this
this is what's going to drive our great
big phenotypic Alzheimer's program
giving the cost given the time the
expense the effort of doing Alzheimer's
trials I don't think so I don't think
anyone's got that amount more right now
so we're going to see what these
mechanism-based compounds are in the
clinic do but beyond that we're going to
have to come up with more mechanism
based compounds I guess because I don't
see any way to just come in with any
sort of we're all based we don't know
how this works that it works like tone
down we have a few questions from people
who are wondering about making the
transition from academia to industry and
um people who are not you know a grad
student but who have been working in
academia for two years I wondered if you
had any advice on that whether it's
don't do it or some specific steps or
skills that folks might be trying to
take in order to kind of make that
transition okay that's a good question
the first thing I can recommend is that
there's a book that they should read is
when did I reviewed on the blog some
months ago and it was all about making
that transition from academia it was a
very well-written thing it had a lot of
very sound advice in it the first thing
I would do is the author's been lucky
for this I just wish I had the title to
hand but the first thing I would do is
go and read this it was from a an
academic group that has actually done
this transition and it has a lot of very
good lessons in it about what surprised
them and what they didn't expect these
are going to be a lot of things that
surprising that you don't expect not all
of this stuff in the book is favorable
toward academic science you have to be
ready for that so I think you have to be
braced for a different world industrial
resource
is both more freewheeling than a lot of
academics think and also a little more
rigorous than while academics tink
we don't just all sit around all day
trying to figure out what what color the
box is going to be and what the slogan
is going to be that we put on the sides
of the balloons it's extremely difficult
and you need a lot of people that most
academic researchers don't have access
to there's a lot of very specialized
work
toxicology formulations pharmacokinetics
only to lead on and on and on that we
really don't find these folks in
academia as much partly because it's
very hard to run a ph.d program and say
formulations so these are specialists we
do this all the time they're very good
at what they do
but if you've never interacted with it
it's a different world entirely so if
you're going to get into industry from
academia you have some studying to do
but keep in mind all of us who are in
industry we can't look through academia
so we know a bit of what it's like back
in academia it's just that academics
often don't know anything about what
it's like in industry read the book
though that always starts you off on the
right path and then have an open mind be
prepared for things not to be like your
preconceptions and be prepared for it to
be very hard because it is
okay um a general question about your
blog you've been doing this for over 10
years now and I wondered if you could
talk about um what your motivation is to
keep doing that you know that's it's a
long time to be writing about the
industry you know what keeps you
motivated also I wondered if you could
talk about how your relationship with
your audience has changed over the years
um you know I think when I started
reading you it was in the early days of
your blog and there's such a civil
discourse that's going on and as you
know journals and and investors alike
lie in the comments to learn little
tidbits about what's going on inside
companies so I'm curious if you could
talk about just that relationship with
your audience and how you've maintained
it and how it's changed over the years
sure well as far as what motivates me I
don't know I like writing about this
stuff we can't rule out the entity
either but I like writing about this
stuff I've always been a pretty quick
writer but that is a very little use in
drug discovery being able to give a good
talk is nice and it doesn't hurt at all
but it's not as if much use in drug
discovery either because I can't go down
and talk to the cells in the dish or
there are the rats and the cages and you
know exhort them to do what I want my
speech making qualities just our kind of
bearing in that in that area so I've
decided that I should use whatever
abilities I have to write and
communicate this stuff to do it this way
and it's I've gotten used to it in the
mornings I just feel bad if I if I don't
write something on the blog because most
mornings I do so the good thing is that
that material is always coming very
rarely do I ever sit down in front of
the keyboard I write this on the train
right into work very rarely do I ever
sit down and think oh gosh what am I
going to write now I usually have
several things queued up my brows
my kids make fun of me my browser always
has about 20 tabs open I have things in
email I have stuff written down on
little notes and etc so I had things
cued up right about most the time so I
just enjoyed it it's you know some
people drink coffee we're saying the
morning I don't even drink coffee I'm
pretty weird my wife can't figure out
how I stay on two legs instead of doing
that I write about some some scientific
news as far as the relation with the
audience I think it's been pretty
similar once I started to have an
audience it took a while I mean if I go
back to the early days it took a while
before people noticed that there was
such a blog and readership has just been
climbing and climbing over the years I
have been really really happy with the
way the comment section works I have all
sorts of other people journalists and
other and other people who run blogs and
internet sites ask me how do you do that
and the answer is I didn't do it the
people who are interested this kind of
thing came to the site and this is the
sort of atmosphere in the sort of
community that generated and I am just
really really happy about it there's not
a lot of craziness in the comment
section for the most part a few but
there's not a lot of ad hominem a lot
not a lot of yomama to use the
vernacular form of a dominant there's
just a very high signal-to-noise if
you're not reading the comments on the
blog you're missing a lot of the best I
just hope nothing ever happens to mess
it up and it looks like the comments
section is going on pretty well at the
new site so I'm just happy as could be
about it oh I want to mention one other
thing readers have chimed in about the
book that I was trying to remember here
it is it's called a practical guide to
drug discovery in academia a spark
approach so practical guide to drug
development in academia that's the one
to look out for
I'm going to ask about something that
you blog about pretty regularly um or
maybe it feels regular since you've been
blogging for so many years never reading
for so many years but it's about the
relationship between industry and
academia and you've seemed to have some
skepticism about the various approaches
that companies are taking to try to dig
in deeper to academia and opens you know
these kind of open source efforts I
wondered if you could talk a little bit
about things that you think aren't
working and whether you think there are
any models that are working about how
companies and academia academic
scientists can work together whether
they exist or don't exist or are there
things that you think could work okay
okay one thing that comes to mind is you
occasionally see the idea advance that
industry has all these wonderful drug
candidates they're just sitting on the
Shelf gathering dust because we're lazy
or we're not too smart or the managers
lost track of what projects they were
doing after the 14th merger in a row
there are a few things like that I'm
sure but for the most part I don't think
they're incredible vast treasure troves
of neglected drugs sitting around you
know in our cabinets so that's one thing
that I think some people need to think
about art if that's going to be their
model is we're going to we're going to
find all this stuff that that industry
has just totally forgotten about there
will be a few I mean Homer sometimes
nods but there's not like dozens and
dozens and dozens of them just sitting
around I have been skeptical over the
years of some of the academic approaches
in the drug discovery but I have to say
it's gotten a lot better one reason for
that might be because there are well a
number of people from industry who have
ended up in academia some of them
voluntarily and some of them did it by
virtue of having leaving somewhere to go
from
the end result has been that there are
more people in the academic chemistry
and biology partners than ever before
who really do know and understand
something about real-world drug
discovery and by real-world I'm afraid
I'm using as a synonym for industrial
because as I was saying in the previous
answer there are just a lot of things
that are part of the process that you
hardly ever find outside industry but
there are a lot more people now who know
about this and we've had some experience
with it and the connections between
academia and industry are the stronger
than they ever were now we still regard
each other with some mutual
incomprehension and some suspicions at
worst the academics look at the
industrial people and think here are
these folks who don't know how to do
basic research anymore all they do is
yank ideas from other people and off and
they comment on it and of course the
industrial chemists look at the academic
ones or the scientists in general and
say here are these folks in their ivory
tower worrying about grant applications
all the time never realizing how much
actual work it is between a need idea
and a drug and how many places it can go
off the rails so we get frustrated with
each other but I think the two are
actually while they're not you know hand
and glove they're closer than they've
ever been at least during my career
um so we've had a few questions from
viewers about layoffs and downsizing in
pharma I mean obviously your blog has a
go-to source for folks to give tips when
the layoff is happening and a lot of a
lot of us who are journalists read it
about read about those layoffs on your
blog first but I you know could you just
give a little sense of what the
temperature is like out there I mean
have we reached some sort of homeostasis
in terms of big pharma layoffs or you
know give us a sense of what what that's
like and maybe if you have a sense of
what the job market is like for say a
graduate student who's looking for their
first job in the pharma industry sure
well as for layoffs and big pharma all
right of the part of the reason things
don't seem quite as bad as like other
they've already laid off some heat and
many people I mean there's just how many
more can you cut but as we saw in GSK
turned around and closed research
triangle and when bristol-myers Squibb
turned around and closed wallingford
there are more places to cut so you
really can't rule this stuff out both of
those had been rumored for a long time
the people who are working at those
sites were always a little bit on the
nervous side excuse me on the nervous
side because they kept thinking we're
not at the mothership you know we're
gonna be peripheral but it was sort of
shocked when those things happen and a
lot of people are still losing their
jobs so no you can't say that the big
pharma layoffs are over and there could
always be another big merger someone
could turn around and for one of these
things tomorrow you know Pfizer was
after AstraZeneca so heavily they could
turn around decide they need to go in
for someone else probably not someone in
the US because they still need to solve
their their attache problems but in
general these things are always in there
that's the unnerving part of being on
the you know in a public business if
someone if you're working for a company
a public company someone can turn around
tomorrow
and make a run at you decide to it for
you maybe they'll be spending too much
money maybe they'll be making a mistake
what people have spent too much money
and people make mistakes doing this it
could happen any time so I wish I could
say that layoffs are well I think in the
past but no they're not as far as coming
into the industry what that means is I
think and I've been saying this for some
years now I think that the balance of
people who are looking in the industry
maybe will be shifting you've got fewer
people a somewhat smaller percentage
working for the really big companies and
a correspondingly larger percentage
working for a longer list of smaller
companies that's not necessarily better
or worse it's just different and it's
just different if you're going into that
job market to because it means for one
thing you're probably going to be
hopping around from company to company
because one of the things about these
smaller companies is they don't all make
it they're a little bit like projects
inside a larger company they come and
they go so you'll need to be ready to me
hopefully not need physically that often
which is the other factor that also
means that one thing to keep out and
look out for is you may well end up
moving to the Boston Cambridge area or
the San Francisco Bay Area maybe San
Diego etc because there are more
companies there of course that means if
something goes wrong you can perhaps
find another job without having to crawl
to moving bands whereas if you are
working for the only company that's
doing in you know oncology in
southeastern North Dakota well that goes
down the tubes you're probably going to
be moving somewhere so it's
nerve-racking like that there isn't
really much job security in this
business anymore I think there used to
be when I was at a previous company I
saw someone who is celebrating like
their 30th year of the company and I
thought even then I'm never going to see
this again I never had I don't know if
he ever will if you know that coming in
and you're not surprised by it or
dismayed by
but you've already come to terms with it
it's going to go a lot smoother for you
so we all have Austin - no I I wanted to
ask you about you know kind of chemistry
breakthroughs because you know one of
the things that you do really well is
write about some of these big academic
break sirs and how they relate to you
know your job things like you know
inserting artificial base pairs in the
living cells or Marty Burks you know
synthesis machine and so you know I just
wondered if any of these recent
developments stood out to you as a
technology that's gonna change the way
you do your job or change the way in
five years or ten years medicinal
chemists are gonna do their job you know
is there anything that you really have
just said wow that's that's super cool
and is gonna change the way that we're
doing chemistry in the future yeah well
the two that I can think of you
mentioned the synthesis machine Rory for
the comment section that you rubbed on
the blog when I start talking about that
as it is currently constituted that
machine is not going to come in and
change medicinal chemistry and even in a
much improved version it's not going to
come in and remake the landscape but I
think that something like it more
automated type of chemistry is
inevitable we've had sort of wrote a
romance for a long time in chemistry
that everything is done by hand and
there's no substitute for adding
everything yourself in some cases
there's enough but there are a lot of
very routine reactions out there Suzuki
couplings come to mind like are used in
works machine there are a lot of very
routine reactions out there and in
general I think that something like that
that can be done by a machine should be
done by a machine and there are a lot of
bread-and-butter organic reactions that
I think are becoming more and more
in abortive being done by machine now I
first saw a machine during organic
synthesis when I was in graduate school
I was at an ACS National meeting and saw
one of the old side mark robot arms
growing around you know supposedly
optimizing a reaction it wasn't working
that well but even at the time I
panicked a bit I was in grad school so I
thought oh my god someone's have been at
the mechanical grad student I better get
my PhD fast but it is coming and I think
it's a good thing running Suzuki
reactions all day long is not very
exciting we should be using our hands
and using our brains for something else
other than setting these things up over
and over so automated synthesis
mechanical assistance is one thing as
far as sheer chemistry I mentioned this
on the blog the other day one of the
things I like very much is all the
further redox chemistry that's coming
out some of that lets you do things that
you can do by other means just by a
different and maybe easier or a cleaner
way to do it some of the reactions there
are things that are not all that easy to
do and I think this field is just
getting started the redox potentials
involved in these in these total
chemical catalysts are very large
there's a lot of energy there and I
think if you pick the right Co catalysts
and get the catalytic cycle working in
the right way there's going to turn out
to be a lot of very interesting
transformations it has the potential to
be as big a change as Palladium
couplings were Suzuki couplings etc were
in the late 80s early 90s so I'm very
much looking forward to seeing if that
prediction comes out
well it was speaking of hot technology I
wanted to bring back this CRISPR notion
I mean I think and you you brought up
the anti sense craze in the 80s and that
everyone thought that was gonna blow
away drug discovery and and be the
answer to all our problems and obviously
it hasn't played out that way can you
talk to me a little bit about CRISPR and
how you say it fits into you know the
drug discovery paradigm and I'd also
like for you to talk about chemistry and
CRISPR I mean you know what roles do
chemists play I mean is this kind of is
it up to tennis to solve some of the
delivery problems that might happen with
getting getting that delivered maybe you
could just talk about that a bit sure
well Chris Berg delivery is a chemistry
problem or formulations problem or
formulations chemistry problem so yeah
that is one place that chemistry can
definitely play a role I think that
there are some therapeutic areas that
have the potential to be remade by this
kind of technology and others not
because of course Chris crew in the end
is a gene editing technology there are
diseases that are specifically strongly
tied to the genome and there are
diseases that are not you can look in
you know metabolic bases have inherited
disease database and find plenty of
small orphan type diseases that we know
exactly the mutation that's behind them
things like this eventually are going to
be where Christopher gets applied and I
suspect that you know the various
companies out there doing it are looking
to pick them off one by one
I'm not going to talk about you know
somatic cells and and germline type
editing does that that's coming
eventually but just for now the other
thing though is is that even some of
these diseases it may be that the cell
types that you need to edit are not
going to be so easy to access or to
access cleanly
just because of physical problems
because of isolation from other cells
maybe because of cell turnover not all
these things are going to are going to
be as easy to do the other thing though
about CRISPR is that there are a lot of
diseases that are not tied to genetics
very well people have of course been
searching and searching for genetic
links to autoimmune diseases rheumatoid
arthritis type 1 diabetes they've been
searching for good genetic links to type
2 diabetes and susceptibility to it
Alzheimer's how many searches have been
done to the genome looking for
Alzheimer's genes I think we can say
there is no Alzheimer's gene someone
would have found it by now if there were
really a reasonable Alzheimer's gene
candidate so what is Chris we're going
to do for you but Alzheimer's when you
would have to know a heck of a lot more
about it before we go in and start
talking about do some kind of gene
editing to improve it and we just don't
know that much so I think where CRISPR
really has the biggest near-term
disruptive potential is in small orphan
and alien type diseases the interesting
thing of course is there are a lot of
companies targeting those small
Mendelian diseases and they have very
big financial plans based around them so
I think everyone who's missing in that
area is keeping a very close eye on the
gene editing technologies because that's
that has the tendency that the potential
will really shake things up but it's too
early to say when that shake-up is going
to occur where it's going to occur first
and how thoroughly things are going to
get shaken once it's started
and I have another question as you might
expect you're getting a lot of questions
about the job market job market um you
know this is one about the sort of
career ladder and whether it even exists
at this point in industrial chemistry
this person is asking whether you would
recommend younger chemists go deep or
broad in their fields of inquiry maybe
you can tackle that one I want to touch
on that a little bit earlier but that
kind of gets back to Aristarchus again
in the fox and hedgehog stuff you know
that the Fox knows many things but the
Hedgehog knows one big thing I think
that you're probably better off being a
little bit more broad than deep the
thing is you have to be prepared to go
deep or deeper on topics as they come up
targets of opportunity but I think you
should probably keep your default
setting more broad to be looking for
ideas technologies targets biology
techniques whatever could be affecting
drug discovery I think you need to be
looking at that as broadly as possible
because ideas can come from anywhere but
a lot of the best ones come from
synthesizing with two fields if you're
the chemist who knows a lot more about
field X than most chemists do that's an
advantage that is an advantage for you
and it's an advantage for discovering
something I like to quote AJ Liebling he
was writing for the new for The New
Yorker back in the in the 40s and 50s he
used to say that his secret was that he
was faster than everyone who was better
and he was better than everyone who was
faster he would've made a pretty good
blogger if he were serious about that
but that's the sort of sweet spot you
need to be into I think you need to be
to know more as a chemist you need
know more about some of these biology
and analytical technical areas then your
average chemist does but you can't be a
deep expert on all of these things but
you can go around and say okay here are
the ones that I think are actually
pretty interesting or pretty neat that I
don't see other people messing with
around here maybe I should learn a
little bit more about this so I can
decide for myself if this is something
good or if I can think of something to
do with it so I guess that's my answer
is we're all but selectively deep and be
ready to ditch something if it turns out
it's not working out and be ready to hit
the literature again if there's some new
thing that comes up and say alright I
have to sit down and learn this stuff
being a quick study is indispensable
that may be ashamed because there are
people who are not quick studies who the
Hedgehog types who end up really digging
into a topic and finding things that you
can't find out otherwise unless you dig
into it for years but I don't think
that's really happening in drug
discovery I don't think it's been that
way historically and I don't think it's
been that way for a long time so in the
same way that that securities
wavefunction blog was mentioning
recently I believe drug discovery is
more of a field for foxes than hedgehogs
so keep it in mind for what it's worth
I'll make this the last sort of
chemistry wonky question since we're
running out of time but I I wondered if
you could weigh in on phenotypic
screening I think I think there's
there's been an ongoing debate there and
some of the readers are asking questions
about you know where you fall what are
your thoughts on the future of
high-throughput screening and what's
going to be the most effective
or I like being a typic screening a lot
but I have to put in a word of caution
they're a bad phenotypic screen is the
worst of both worlds that is the abyss
by bad I mean one that is not
necessarily predictive of the disease
that you're studying and that's the hard
part
setting up a good phenotypic screen is
really difficult partly because the
kinds of targets for studying now
probably it's just intrinsically
difficult to find a model on the
cellular small animal or rodent for have
you to find a biological model like that
that you are confident enough to go with
because when you get down to it if
you're going to be seriously
phenotypically screening something you
have to have enough nerve to run your
thumb to screen your compounds in this
to develop your compounds against this
and then when you've got a good-looking
compound and you've done a little
testing for pique and you've got no
testing for toxin it seems to work at
European take extreme there's nothing
left to do you have to hold your breath
cross your fingers and go into man you
have to go into the clinic with it and
that's a big leap that's kind of a broad
jump to make if you're not ready to make
that you need to either you know steal
your yourself screw your courage to the
sticking-place as Shakespeare put it all
you need to rethink your commitment your
running the phenotypic screen in the
first place because you're just going to
be wasting your time so is your
phenotypic screen solid enough do you
have enough confidence in it to be able
to make that leap eventually because
that's what you're headed for so a good
phenotypic screen is a wonderful thing I
don't think we know nearly enough
biology when you certainly don't know as
much as we sometimes think we do and a
good phenotypic screen is their way to
discover the way to find things out that
we didn't even know that we knew what a
bad phenotypic screen is a waste of time
and if it's a really simple easy thing
to set up the chances of it being a bad
phenotypic screen are increased
so are there therapeutic areas that
you're really looking forward to us
making some significant progress on in
the coming years maybe you could talk a
little bit about sort of aspirationally
you know what we what problems we might
be able to solve in the next few years
that you think are really you know the
tough ones and I guess I'm hoping we can
end on a aspirational death for drug
discovery
well you mentioned an you know oncology
before a lot of the stuff happening in
the oncology and cancer field is very
exciting and I'm optimistic about that
area I think that we're getting I mean
we talked about epigenetics I'm very
interested to see what happens that area
I think there's going to be some big
failures but probably some pretty nice
successes - maybe not successes that
people were expecting or successes in
the way that they were looking for but
I'm looking forward to seeing what
happens in there some of the other areas
Alzheimer's I don't have as much hopeful
in the near term I hope to be wrong
about that I'm hoping that we're getting
a little bit better handle on diseases
of protein misfolding
that's a good area to be in very hard
but there's a lot of stuff out there
infectious diseases I think that area if
we get the sort of you know terrible
Berlant plague type stuff that people
worry about then yeah we're going to go
crazy with that as it is now it's been
very hard I have a tremendous amount of
respect for bacteria because they are so
hard to kill I don't know how many
mammalian cells I've killed over the
years for killing bacteria especially
gram-negative bacteria on demand it's
very hard unless you're you're using a
bleach or something like that
and it works okay but you know bleach is
not very good therapeutic agent so I
would hope for some
breakthroughs in anti-infective but i
don't really know where they're coming
from the good thing is is that it's a
lot easier to set up meaningful
phenotypic screens in bacterial and
viral infections so I'm hoping for good
things to come out there but it's it's
it's really kind of crapshoot
so overall I guess oncology is the area
that I'm most happy about and the
spillover from all the amino oncology is
just the other immune diseases so the
autoimmune area and then as you get on
from there into the inflammation so
immune energy inflammation stuff I think
we're going to see a lot of spillover
from that as we start to learn more
about the immune system from all these
oncology applications that area I'm very
I'm very actually keen on seeing what
happens next
okay one last question I think we have
time for um this might be too big of a
barrier the last question but I just
wondered if you could talk a little bit
about the pharmaceutical industry and
reputation obviously between drug
pricing and um adverse events that come
up after a drug is approved there
there's kind of a the industry gets kind
of a bum rap and I wondered if you could
talk about what what scientists could do
to help change that that perception I
don't know how much we can do I mean
that's one of the reasons I started the
blog is I've found that people that I
talk to you outside the field had no
idea for drug discovery was like they
had no idea that people even had a job
during drug discovery people still don't
I mean it's it's too big a mound of
ignorance to shovel out so easy the
industry does get a bad rap some of it
deserved some of our pricing ideas are
not sustainable and some of the things
that we're generating are not providing
enough benefit for those prices however
others are there are drugs that are
expensive that are worth it because they
do a lot that's our challenge is to come
up with
that are worth the prices that we would
like to charge for them now as far as
the reputation with adverse events every
drug that everyone takes is an
investigational drug honestly I would
like to see every prescription bottle
have a label on it that says I
understand that I am participating in a
post approval trial of an
investigational medicine because nothing
is settled everything we're still
learning about stuff drugs have been on
the market for years and years so
everything is an investigational drug
more or less forever so adverse events
are always going to be with us we cannot
predict these things well enough the FDA
would like for us to be able to but how
big a clinical trial can you run if this
is going to be a drug taken by X million
people so some of them some of the bad
reputation the industry is deserved some
of it isn't we as an industry would be
out of a lot of our trouble if we
delivered some drugs that really
dramatically work people wouldn't
complain so much about what they cost if
we can deliver a real benefit that's our
challenge
okay well I think that's all we have
time for thank you so much Derek for
letting everyone pick your brain
we all appreciate your insightful
commentary on the drug industry and
thanks to all of our viewers for tuning
in I think there's still some more talks
left on our agenda you can find the full
program on the agenda page at the upper
right hand of your screen and in the
meantime you can stop by the virtual use
a bit Hall in the lounge to check out
our sponsors and exhibitors or to
network with other attendees and if you
want to check back in on Twitter to join
the conversation again the hashtag is C
e & sy m15 thank you so much